[Applause]
hey guys sorry for the light delay
we're actually if you heard those those
are game noises it's me Eric that's Erin
we're playing hunt showdown new game
from Crytek closed alpha it is kind of
like a mix of PvP and PvE I'm gonna let
Erin try to describe it as best as he
can because he knows a little bit more
about the game than I do but he's with
Rob handler II you're gonna hear him
over the voice chat it's to be two's
yeah apparently he can hear that
yeah means basically this game is if
left for dead and escape from tarkov had
a baby okay that's that's pretty much it
in a nutshell so what we're doing is we
are you spawn on the map with a with
other teams of two several Oh teams of
two you followed these blue points here
on the map with your ghost Oh vision
they are clues and then after you get a
certain number of clues and Robert stay
away from Mecca and our left so after
you get a certain number of clues it
narrows it down to where the boss
monster is so here's one here Rob's
about to grab it and then you basically
fight the boss if you are the first team
there or if you don't want to be first
scene there you wait for other teams to
do it for you and then you extract so
there's gunshots here in the background
there's OD is the main objective to kill
the boss monster or the other players or
is it both so the main objective is to
kill the boss monster and extract with
I don't know what it is like soul lute
or something like that okay and then you
level up your characters but this is
where the escape from tarkov thing comes
in if you die you lose your so you have
a bunch of hunters if you die you lose
your your hunters permanently so then
you have to buy more hunters oh okay
the way that the Alpha is working right
now hey you can hear the players
shooting the whole time it's like one of
the best strategies is just go quiet for
most of it usually you run into the
other players around the or right now
see we ran down like they look at you
guys being tactical yeah so if you die
you lose your hunters and in the Alpha
right now they just give you more
hunters I don't know what that I don't
know they're gonna do the escape from
tarkov thing in the final build where
you I don't like you have to earn enough
points to buy more hunters we'll find
out you find any other weapons along the
way or is this kind of what you're dealt
with the kind of like two holding each
other so there's quite a few weapons you
can unlock right now there's a library
of them that you can buy okay and
there's a pretty good unlock tree the
weapons look pretty cool like they're I
don't know what what I remembered like
the game the order they're a lot like
that but okay like plague type World War
one ding ding 84 we are playing hunt
showdown it's the new game from Crytek
this is just the closed alpha though so
checking it out and seeing if our boys
here Aaron and Rob can get a victory
either by hopefully killing this there's
like a month like a big monster that you
want to kill
but there's also other players that are
on the map so there's like a pvp and PVE
element to this game most the time
players kill you
just just gonna throw this out there
most the time you get shot in the back
it's kind of outworks
if you kill the boss do you still have
to try to extract it while other people
could potentially kill you yeah I mean
there's like it's like that division
almost a little bit so other players
know where you are at all times
once you get the final piece of loot and
then you have to get your extraction
point and there's still a countdown
timer at that point so where are you oh
it's past the big giant monster i Rob
it's directly north of us apparently my
push-to-talk is too strong too strong no
tell Rob he's got to deal with it
alright we're going with that let's go
that way
see ya okay there's definitely guys to
the west of us so carefully also I think
I turned my light on there we go okay oh
we're okay inside where the house
yeah shoot east
Ravi shooting at him there inside that
house for sure mo is also limited in
this game but you can pick it up race
also I think I saw something
okay let's shift position because they
know exactly where we are you want to
shift back into the barn because
otherwise they're going to come out a
random spot I don't know if we can
change oh no oh and Rob goes down Oh Rob
said like I said players are the
greatest enemies so like that's
interesting
nope oh right over his head you covering
the revive oh so you can't revive okay
that's cool yeah no no you're good I
think you're good okay
run into the house I don't know if Rob's
good running into the house right away
yeah we got to get out the back here if
we can we're gonna leave he knows where
we are all right follow me serpentine
serpentine book it what did you do drop
all you uh yeah okay are you dead Rob
okay let's circle around yep I see him
he's down below
he's running they're both running just
so you know they're being engaged give a
grenade my chance you know that you can
abs alright just in case cuz chats
telling you you can how do you left
shift wall push left shift to 80s wow
there's a lot of buttons yeah surprise
hi uh sky onyx thanks for the tip so I
do not have a grenade with this yeah it
looks like you can revive down teammates
I want to save Rob probably wasn't full
life maybe half life or something like
that I'll revive
I want to get these guys real bad oh
where the right he says he's propriety
now your left oh he killed one nice is
he down or is he out or both okay
where's the other dude you're pulling
zambese where are you getting shot at
where are you okay he's on the top when
you save the house where we were now
there's the thing we need to get up and
somebody's already banishing the spider
where where what yeah is that actual
people or all right where's yet the the
big roof or any work is the way to
victory yep always this game is
basically a western version of pokey
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know about that they're
zombies he shoot through the door is he
in there it's crazy that you can hear
that oh there's a liar
he's a liar he's right there what a
filthy liar
you wanna I could try knifing him got
him he's down all right he's down yeah
I don't know I don't think you can loot
anybody's range so okay when you said
when we saw the spider is being banished
that is that the big boss yeah I mean
that means we're not doing the right
thing right now we're supposed to go to
where the spiders being banished but
instead you're doing the people I'm Way
more excited that we actually killed
somebody
are you sure you kill them he's where is
he we do you limp off cumshaw nope nope
nope this thing here it's got problems
maybe slightly diseased ow oh you can
you can you can actually hurt each other
or team you know that was just you just
from a bleeding okay yeah
pressing tab you'll see them that folks
on the map yep so we should be going
here okay you're not too far but I want
to I don't know like Robin and we're
trying to kill people earlier and I'm
kind of excited we actually drop
somebody I think they would laugh dude
there is always dead there you are f to
loot too bad we can't all right go after
you let er go with stop the spiders okay
it's gonna stop spiders assuming you can
go stop the spider let's go get out of
this bushes all right nope we're heading
in the wrong wrong direction
other way get janked okay here we go
this way
Rob's on the case he's ahead at 105 oh
it's got it even has the Pope G compass
thing 105 in spiders all right uh grant
wasn't singing grant willson 88 saying
so the aim is to take out the monster
first than the other players or is it
free-for-all oh it's both it's like kind
of both yeah so there's no so like okay
so the reason you don't want to die is
because you you have to like you know
obviously you lose your hunter
permanently and you have to get new ones
but what is the answer what is the big
incentive for you to like try to play
properly and not just grief people I
think there's a pretty big incentive to
drop other teams before you get to the
monster OOP the live shootin going down
right now because you want to thin out
the herd so that you get this stuff yeah
just like 45 to 60 shooting going on
over there um so Oh tracking in the dark
site
okay so now we're gonna figure out where
they are you'll see like a giant
lightning strike okay so they're
straight they're at 120 does one of them
have to carry it thus leave it leaving
them kind of like useless or is it not
like that they so from what I saw we
haven't done it yet but from what I saw
and the video the Deaf sent us they're
like me by the way like that shows off
where I am two other players you want to
be real careful there's there's horses
that you can wake up there's birds that
show off your position there's dogs that
bark and okay so back the question you
have to extract you have to get this
riverboat and stay there for 20 seconds
I'm assuming you can defend yourself
that whole time okay but okay so that's
where they are I mean we all know where
they are
um so let me talk about the the pace of
this game so the first couple rounds we
played what happened was by about the
first or second clue we usually singed
pretty easily then by the third clue we
would start running into other teams and
if you move too fast those teams you'll
just get murked like go to shoot you in
the back and that's the end of it so a
lot of this game I think is about oh
maybe they're just holding up in there
oh no I see you team they're right there
they're trying to cross the bridge at 15
let's see if we get ahead of them does
it become so if you eliminate all the
other players does it just become you
trying to kill the big monster then or
whatever that monster is if the monster
is not dead at that point yeah yeah so
it's basically PVE pvp that then becomes
PvE or it's a combination of the both as
it is right now as we try to pick off oh
oh we're okay well where they go they
were running northeast what if that was
actually just a zombie and we thought it
was a person you zombie vision okay so
there and we know where they are but we
don't know where the other players are
that's the that's the problem so like do
you know how many does it tell you
indicate how many other hunters are
still alive or no I do not believe so
okay
so they are they make it tunics yeah it
seems like that grant willson yeah so we
probably know where they're going
they're probably headed to this
extraction point here oh so okay really
okay so they're just gonna keep heading
I mean we probably to hustle they're
probably just gonna keep heading
Northwest until they get to that
extraction point
[Music]
okay gotta stop them so you want dilute
so that's not entirely true though so if
you died trying to stop them you lose
your hunter so okay so they got it right
yeah they already got it so that
probably means we want to extract so if
we want to keep our hunters
Gogi if we go there we're gonna get new
gun fight which is more entertaining but
let's do it
realistically you might want to extract
to a place where other players arts
because then you get to keep your hunter
and when you keep your hunter you get to
level them up and add more helpful when
you say extract as in like escape if the
bounty is taken your your goal then
still is to get out of the map yeah okay
so like escape from tarkov
it's just there's a there's a steam boat
once you get there there I think it was
a twenty second timer all right
can't they just leave to you though
technically oops this is what happens
when you hit tab okay so it's actually
stopped just to our left is the
extraction those dogs will give away
your position to you yeah we are all
right
oh so okay mission and inform it so you
so other people you don't necessarily
want to get right to the steam boat
because the steam boat there's a timer
there too so if there's other players
waiting to kill people extracting then
so what if you're not an extraction
point when the timer is up have another
that happened yet but maybe you go to
hell and lose your honor
okay you can't go through that way okay
that works game saying no forcing
carriages flying is that the extraction
hang on that might be it that's it but
okay so we go there
and there's other players now whatever
you want to go there I mean you're
pretty much there all right we're gonna
be sitting ducks for any other players
also extract you to this point we might
be okay why don't you go from twenty to
ten is it cuz both of you are in it yeah
whoa there's faster faster if there's
two yeah we got out with our hunters all
right and we actually dropped another
team I'm happy that's a good day yeah
nice so then you have to you all of that
plus kill a boss monster and that's how
you get the most points out of it
so okay in that case that you were you
just won is just the positive there that
you made it out with your hunter because
what did you really net out of that
other than like oh I didn't lose my
hunter there's actually points and stuff
yeah so I'll show you in the hunter menu
here there's actually points so I can
then it's pretty there's some of it's
pretty significant you can definitely at
least in this alpha you can add a lot of
health to your hunter so I'll just go
that customization screen here real
quick remember guys it is a closed alpha
so it's only four expect a little bit of
jank it's only for 24 hours so he's he's
a level seven that's your guy yeah so I
can upgrade him I don't I have six
points right now so not for the stream
let's do this let's give him more health
okay or I can give him 50 hit points
when we get a little bit higher so let's
give him more health oh okay
- and then here's my hunter you can go
to the store so that round I did not
have any grenades which I kind of want
you earn cash through the game yeah and
there's some pretty cool weapons like
this it's like this old fashioned chain
pistol thing this is a suppressed
version which is really important for
not drawing other players like if you
just start popping off at the beating
arounds other players will come at you
okay so I need some so like health was
that leveling system in tarkoff to you
it reminds me of a dead bite daylight a
little bit was a linear okay like that
by daylight like you would like level up
you're like you know either
the villain or the
like characters do different trees and
stuff like that not it was a little bit
different than this but that's kind of
cool I guess so I guess you feel that
investment in time with this character
where you don't want to lose them right
yeah um because otherwise if you did die
you'd have to start at zero again it's
also unclear yeah so I I can't tell if
there's like a separate leveling system
going on here also but I know per hunter
they die but that could also give you
know and I think this is a thing that
happened in tarkoff that could give
certain dominant teams a pretty hard
advantage like their win a couple rounds
they get the best gear and then the new
players run out of gear and then you
just have a situation where you have
high-level players with the best gear
just stomping all over low-level players
you can't get a foothold so that's a
risk of a game like this but again I
want to emphasize this is just a in
early alpha build of the game and I mean
Katerine we do not have codes to give
out and fortunately sorry did you enter
now Rob get synced up there yeah how
many maps so far in this alpha one map
day and night ok seems pretty big and
you basically all spawn at different
locations but then you're pretty much
trying to get to that monster right you
do you don't know where the monster is
though until you get a couple of the
clue the clue points and again there's a
huge incentive to not go loud unless you
have to because other players can just
hone right it on you and end your round
this is gonna be a little while it's an
alpha so the loading time takes a while
I'm curious if people out there do you
guys play escape from tarkov do you guys
like the games where you risk it all or
alright like pub G is kind of the
opposite of that it's never fair but you
always start from zero and you never
really gain anything is that appealing
to people
I guess there are two different
approaches to games that are very
punishing loot based games that are
punishing the greatest hunt is this
loading screen yeah it does seem like
there's a pretty extensive unlock tree
though this seems like it from what I
can tell this is just a small slice of
it and even what's here seems pretty
interesting a lot of the pistols fire
very slowly it's like shoot [ __ ] shoot
[ __ ] and I know that I've seen in some
online videos like they have more
rapid-fire pistols and they had burst
fire rifles and one of the hunters here
has a double bit of shotguns some dude
hunted Rob and I down in a crematorium
with it and just annihilated us it was
it was kind of impressive actually Kevin
Lewis
I haven't played too much but the
concept seems interesting I'm just
wondering you know how long people stay
kind of hooked to playing it I guess I
don't know feels like one of the biggest
challenges of a game that makes you lose
all your loot is having a progression
system that still rewards your time we
were actually just having this
conversation about Co thieves to be
honest Nick margarita plays a lot of Co
thieves he's played a lot of see if
these in her office over the past week
and it was one of those games where you
can just invest massive amounts of time
and then for uncertain rewards and then
just lose everything when another team
jacks you yeah and we were just like my
how that game needs me to intermittent
rewards like this is PC only right sorry
to cut you off right now yeah but
there's no word that there's gonna be
any cause or anything they're released
right i I can't I don't really know what
the answers are that we've only seen it
on PC so far and it's only showed out
that well like you'd read last year yeah
I just checked wiki and I think it's
just PC right now
all right Rabb
so usually the first one is good usually
you don't run into players until the
second or third clue do you share clues
though or is it just that they're like
in the same area vicinity there's
definitely a limited number of clues the
other thing that Rob and I haven't done
is go to one of these restock points I
don't know if there's there's a really
cool bomb in the game that I've seen
videos I've called the concertina wire
bomb which actually will walk off an
area so other players or zombies can't
run through it so we gotta get like the
chain sound no codes unfortunately Jane
Hwa chaddock's also our closed alpha is
only good to like 6:00 a.m. tomorrow so
we don't have too much time with it
ourselves even so Tanner Gatlin whoa
this is cool quick explanation of the
game what it was
tarkoff and escape from tarkov and left
for dead left for dead Santa baby had a
baby I'd say that's the most active feel
like there's a little division in there
but maybe I'm just harkening that to
like the the extraction kind of thing
but it there there's that tension right
where all the groups kind of know you're
extracting or you've killed the boss and
that you want to get that loot out and
on top of that as Aaron had mentioned
earlier if you lose your hunter in a
game you actually lose it and you lose
the progression on that Hunter right
yeah right now in the Alpha they are
pretty friendly and they'll just give
you another set of hunters yeah but I
don't know what happens in the real game
if you're gonna real game by one or if
you just get another one they start over
with so there's an incentive obviously
to try to live so that you can you know
make your hunter better hunter and you
know that that brings up other issues
will that create unfair advantages where
such as an escape from tarkov really
dominant teams with the best gear can
just stop all over people who can't
maintain their gear because they keep
getting killed you triggered the bird
zone you need to have a yeah you need to
have a stealth mindset for this game to
be honest I tend to charge into things
which is not the best well how often
have you actually oh zombie oh oh
poison app punch punch my punch a voyage
nope no nope nope nope no so you those
are zombies that spit large piles of
flies and you need to kill them so so
there's a hunter that actually is a
syringe to stop that effect or cure you
you just have to deal with it right now
I just have to deal with it cuz I don't
have that hunter there's also little
there's a healing class Hunter oh so
there are like classes then yeah they're
there they're like classes oh this is
where we last time I mean another viable
option is just to wait and for the other
team to pick out the bounty and then go
hunt them yeah yeah there's a couple of
spots that only have one man or one or
two ways in one or two ways out
wonderfully other teams gonna show up
here yeah I don't know if we're the same
server with them well he'll actually RP
I'm coming out with my hands up just
kidding
that's my gun that dude is rad I would
say we should probably not knife this
fire guy to your left rub because he's
got fire I asked in the bushes
all north and there he says follow him
who robs on the case though zombies do
kind of like me John wait nope hi yes
that answers that question about
friendly fire that's cool no spamming
sounds like he's bad I Rob way don't you
so if they get the clue does that mean
you can't get the clue anymore yeah
that's that's that's the whole point
we're all converging on the same clues
so it's very likely that we will meet
each other at a clue point they may took
the clue the clue is behind you that I
think yeah which is I'm not sure why
they were on this way maybe they were
waiting for the other team to get the
clues and then they can hit it on the
point yeah okay if we start shooting
over there he'll probably circle back on
us so just keep it quiet
what's loud I mean the solo players can
definitely because there's only two of
you they can mess up your day so you can
solo on the other hand if you're good
I mean if you ambush another team you
could probably kill one of them
instantly and then it's just really a
1v1 yeah obviously there's a lot of
environmental hazards oh now you can't
get that life back it looks like I think
I'm doing I okay where's this thing at
okay I should probably back up my buddy
map updated all right do you you so you
never match make with somebody you
either solo or you group up as two shots
about 45 Northeast's I think it's got to
be that solo player we should go we
should gank him no no no no don't shoot
Rob aiming is pretty tough well remember
you can 80s I would rather I haven't
figured how to set the default two irons
I would rather just default irons what
always down site yep and I can make that
right click when they're directly
naughty
oh just zoom in I'm not a huge fan of
site like hit by like yeah of having to
press more than one button to get iron
alright so the maps updated let's see
what it's them let's see what I was
trying to tell us about okay so the maps
now narrowed down so we know the general
direction do you want to just for the
stream Rob do you want to try and hit
the we haven't hit a resupply point yet
I'm curious what's there I'm not sure of
the system requirements yet the real
show uh it's a yeah it's closed alpha so
I don't know if they sent put out min PC
specs or anything else like that yet
Freebirds stop giving away an
intelligent tells a Rob to be quiet
triggers Birds okay so that's it right
come here
oh wow you regen up to the bar I
definitely hear people shooting behind
us North I'm curious what is that these
resupply points what you get am a full
axe ooh
bandages okay that's good so these are
for just animal bandages
and acts it acts as a two-handed weapon
okay so we can start getting down to the
narrow hey did you throw that send me
through a fire bomb at us okay okay
killed it fire banning is happening so
we need to go southeast there's
definitely a team to the north of us so
we got to be really careful about not
getting shot in the back we'll see that
action oh it shows you the vanishing
okay yeah the top left that's cool I
think we got teams to our east and north
let him shoot the spider you shoot them
there's a lot of 10 fight going down hot
action I want to get to the action this
is where we don't want to start shooting
zombies because then everybody's know
what's the max player account in one
game actually don't know if some add its
invited to estimate its seems like five
or six teams of two okay
so we just don't want to you do want to
be careful you don't just get the
zombies on you because no I doesn't
distract you there just lets other teams
know where you are a gun part has
stopped huh oh yeah so shooting as I
speak there straight ahead of us
somewhere do they have to shoot the
monster to banish it okay well there's
people right ahead of us somewhere where
are you so much shooting they could
actually just be shooting the yeah they
might just be fighting the the boss
inside there nope I hear dogs behind us
that means in other players another
player somewhere by holiday nope Rob's
way ahead of me rob is looking for
action I like it Rob's looking for some
live action there's a lot of shooting I
bet they're inside engaging the boss
what was that sounds like a zombie on
guys
[Applause]
well also you're slowing slower in water
anywhere hopefully we'll get into then
the spider killed all of them but it
looks like they're banishing right now
so they're they gotta be they're
probably just in there whenever get in
from the basement any details of
different washers not that we know of I
don't think there's a basement entrance
those watch it there's a cans right here
they gotta kill that they're almost done
killing but Aaron and Rob we're trying
to hunt them down or maybe like okay
kill it and then keep doors open and I
want to see this banishing it sounds
like we're not gonna get to see it
though where are they today we're still
banishing they're in here somewhere you
might be upstairs they'll kill a spider
and kill them this is a closed alpha so
I'm sure it's a very limited amount okay
so now they're just gonna escape we just
need to shoot him in the back wherever
they are okay they're over here
but they will probably at some point
make it open so okay head upstairs
they're right above us oh they're
literally right above us is there way up
there we're grab just yep I think you
just shot Rob you got hitmarkers at that
time though
yeah where they at though
stop the bleeding press f2 headshot how
do I play legends faith you probably got
a sign-up wafer like with an open alpha
or open beta I get around behind this
guy Danny's on the move kind of want to
get around behind him he's right there
should we just go around the corner on
him
Oh to own one baby out oh he's got a
handgun oh he's getting mugged though
hey you guys get the bounty man hey
we're just gonna enjoy our success for a
minute yeah okay tonight they're running
away um I don't know if I can heal you I
mean let me know oh I'm healing you yeah
you're healing both of you
oh nice weird it heals both of you okay
all right you see this okay they're
running that seems like another reason
to have some way to play with
we gotta get chase together they're
running away they're running away there
they're over there man I usually get
accused of compulsive over reloading on
streams I'm glad somebody's finally
telling me to reload well that's let's
go at slow pace through it's like a jog
it's like a like jog or power walking
ankle deep water uh Burke Reynolds this
is Hunt
show down the new Crytek game it's
enclosed alpha I don't think there's a
release date yet it's kind of like a
escape from tarkov
meets left4dead ish a little bit slash
they're extracting oh they're going
pretty far really get around him oh you
can see him on the map
dude they're they're gone they're going
to catfish Grove we should just sprint
if we want to catch him otherwise yeah
we want to catch him for the stream for
sure nobody gets away from Robin Arryn
then means we need to just figuring out
this road will take us there if we just
follow the road - you're not making that
assuming we don't get Oh help dogs dog
find you my dogs they're Dutch the dogs
on you we're out to get dogs Rob don't
care he's faster than dogs
that is shroud and summit a would shout
in the summit we gotta stop shouting
summit all right well if these dogs
they're too big twitch streamers if we
can stop them
we'll be on their stream and that'll be
worth it it's all order my friend no man
you got to believe actually got a real
but they're really I was really good at
pub G and some it's pretty good too
I believe in you guys you guys are you
guys are pretty eSports I can't believe
they're running so far though well they
don't they don't wanna be anywhere near
because then the other teams will just
get him up they must have got there they
got there where do they go anyway okay
all right let's get a shootout
they are probably way way too far ahead
but where's the where's the extraction
point that boat oh we gotta get we're
like not anywhere near it oh really
extraction point is it's a boat it's oh
it's over here yep gonna go this way
they booked it yeah I think they knew
where they're headed
guys stop comparing to tarkoff no one
plays that okay how about the division
meets left4dead meets pub G where's that
boat well that's right Rob if there's a
boat in here somewhere that's the
extraction coop shooting at burger damn
Birds literally doing the exact opposite
of what birds do
I think Rob has given up I'm being quiet
where's the boat we're looking at it it
should be straight ahead it's over here
yeah yeah
Rob's giving up that's the boat right
ahead of us so they didn't go to cafes I
think more people are playing division
than they are playing tarkoff okay the
boat should be right ahead of us let me
bandage up if I have any Pope GE meets
zombie game with extraction in a Western
I mean that's the boat are they here
did they name X can they just leave or
do they have to wait till the last no
they probably just got out why would
they wait ain't nobody gonna wait well
so the two in the in the upper left
corner it kind of tells you all right
well at least we killed someone again
because that didn't beat a man to death
with rifle butts that was shrouded in a
summit hunt damn we could this time we
could try and rush for the monster and
just see what happens you guys weren't
even close to rushing to the monster oh
you mean you're trying to play
tactically there so the past Robin I
played all morning and to be honest
every single time we rushed for the
monster we got shot in the back
hunt like 100% of the time which is why
we're having more fun just ganking other
people yeah but you should always be
going to the monster anyways because you
know a team is trying to kill it
to extract it so you can then kill them
so at the very least if you're not gonna
be able to get the loot out yourself at
least you can kill the people with the
loot and then maybe steal it
got another invite yeah we'll try and
this time around so the map the map
narrows down pretty quickly so I'll pay
attention in the map and we'll try and
get in the zone with the other the other
teams wait pal probably not to start at
least right now I think it's only slated
for PC from what I can tell but you
never know where I take me some pretty
interesting statements about normally
they're very graphically focused but
this time around
they're just trying to get the stability
and the guns and the unlock tree going
didn't sound like they're gonna be too
worried about insane graphics and any
usual conventional way but it does look
pretty good it's just probably need some
optimization
I haven't played their war face game
like that for a little while that was a
game I think that's the best I can say
about the game uh haven't seen the early
access date yet just a game room
I don't yeah I'm not sure about console
it does it like if you look at the
Wikipedia it just says platform is
Microsoft Windows so maybe they start
there and then see how it goes
I think it's on Steam though you can
find it on Steam I will say that's after
playing this for the morning starting
you're pretty familiar with the map so I
think once you get better and you know
where the extraction points are you
start learning um kind of the flow of
the game yeah it's just as coming soon
but it's an early access game so here's
this
so the map also like I said the map is
day-night variance for those of you just
joining us we're playing the hunt
showdown
we just got access to it for a day which
is bet how long this alphas lasting and
its kind of escape from tarkov meets
left4dead bunch players drop in on a map
they look for clues but all the teams on
the map teams of two are looking at the
same clues and they might run into each
other any given time and kill each other
and then after the clues you go find a
monster you kill that monster and
extract if you survive and while other
players try and kill you so it's a
definitely pretty it's leaning in the
hardcore direction you you lose your
hunter when you die so now we've managed
I don't wanna jinx myself but somehow
we've actually not lost our house when
Cersei survived two maps that doesn't
mean that you know I'm gonna survive
them all I do wonder though like if you
start getting that really powerful
hunter with the powerful gear if that's
it's kind of hopefully there's some type
of well you have like hunter rank and
things like that so maybe there's some
type of matchmaking perhaps so that you
don't you know like if you're day one
you shouldn't run into somebody that's
like you know been playing for like a
week or two a lot of this game is also
about the environment paying attention
in the environment so if you're a tune
to what's going on birds flying in the
air dogs barking horses those are all
other players around you triggering
those and particularly the flocks of
birds actually you can probably tell
exactly if you're paying attention to
the sky where other teams are the new
teams will just start shooting and you
know exactly where they are the more
experienced teams won't shoot unless
they have to
no release date yet Danny see I see this
is coming soon I'd be surprised if they
didn't show more off at e3 this year
considering these shows off for the
first time at e3 last year mm-hmm and
this is the first alpha that they've had
but they've got a got to be at that
point out where they're ready to show
more I like the setting a lot actually
the
the horror survival setting is cool and
like the chains that you walk through
that give away your position and there's
just there's a lot of things in the
environment to pay attention to the guns
all look messed up everything's dying
around you it's very late I live very
left for dead I'm just curious like yeah
you obviously want to be careful of like
you know clanging against like the metal
tins and the hooks and things like that
but it only really feels like that
matters if you happen to be like in the
same location I guess but I guess like
you said the clues kind of force players
towards each other so maybe that's how
it how to do it I don't know couldn't
you just in a way wait for them to start
banishing and go like okay I'm gonna go
to where the banishing is and never look
for a clue you could definitely do that
there's a couple of banishing spots like
the crematorium that I think only have
two ways in or out we sat there for five
minutes early this morning waiting for
another teammate to come out and made
the wrong assumption that they'd already
left so Rob and I went in and nope they
just waited for five minutes until we
came in and that was the end of it so
good it's got that it's got that
patients game for sure particularly if
you kill the monster and extract it
everybody knows where you are so I guess
I don't know you've got to move fast or
hole up and just shoot it out yeah the
matchmaking does take a while but this
is just a very early alpha yeah I'm sure
like the thing too is that since it is
it closed off weathers like not as many
people playing probably two so it's
gonna take a second to get a match
obviously with any guys for tuning in
interesting game for sure we're not
doing necessarily a lot of zombie
killing just because this morning again
we did a lot of zombie killing and
discover two other teams just queuing on
where you are really fast when you do
that which is one of the reasons why
we're not actually showing us that means
Ami's not really a benefit to killing
the zombies outside of like if they're
chasing you or getting them out of the
way right so I don't know or is there
there more there to make you go around
yeah and
maybe used to mess with other teams or
you know you if you push it another team
up against zombies at least it's a
distraction there's some tough ones
there's a heavy one for sure that runs
after you and is a tank and hard to kill
senator Chang gamers you can play by
herself but obviously if you play by
herself is gonna be tough like as you
saw with that one guy he was trying to
fight Robin Arryn with you know his gun
as he would and then Robin Arryn said
screw it and they just went and mail ate
him to death and he couldn't do anything
about it I'm sure if he had like a
shotgun though one of them why would it
died if not both yeah if you're playing
by yourself your goals more or less to
find another team and if you can drop
the first guy before the second guy
knows what's going on then it's just a
1v1 and you got a decent chance alright
we found a match
we definitely I've definitely played
solo a little bit this morning and I've
definitely seen other players doing it
in a way solo players kind of suck
because they're outliers they're not
necessarily ever gonna win but they can
still mess up your day um Wade Powell
its pvp and PVE combined so it's like
pvp and yes because ultimately your PvE
to kill the said monster to get the like
loot that you want to extract but the
PvP part of it is either running into
players along the way as you get to that
monster to get that hot loot or you're
killing those people that are trying to
extract to get the loop before they get
out and then as Aaron mentioned earlier
the fear that you will have potentially
when you play this game is that you have
a hunter that you have invested time
into and leveled that if you do lose it
then that hunter is gone and you have to
either use one of your spares or start a
new one so I don't want to jinx it but
these are the best two rounds Rob and
I've had all morning great we did not
extract once in the morning we died it
we got shot in the back every time
because we rushed the clues which is why
you'll see us playing much more slowly
now wait pal I think it's just this for
now I don't I have
of anything else but again closed alpha
so just stay tuned I'm sure we'll cover
it more as the game comes out or more
stuff so we're starting where we
extracted the last time I believe
showing off yeah I actually don't think
I bought any more med packs which I
should've done between rounds so maybe
we'll go to a supply point now that
stoves in that backs I'm good
shitty up okay Caesar's ghost vision
ghost Oh vision shows us the blue stuff
that gives us the clues mm-hmm is it
three clues before you find the the
spider as it is for this one we haven't
got the spider the spider clue yet but
again the video that I watched I think
like the third or fourth clue it's
probably the fourth clue you actually
see you find us Rob you actually see
what the spider sees yeah so there's a
little spiderweb here so that like I'm
assuming there's gonna be a variety of
monsters in the final building
have you seen the spider yet have not
fought the spider ourselves the horror
show wants to know how many weapons you
can carry it can you carry at one time
[Music]
starting off - but I saw slots for I
think up to four I'd next time we die
that doesn't look healthy so yeah next
time we die I'll go and look in the menu
dang die you mean more like when next
time we win some we kill popular
youtubers who know exactly what they're
doing
we'll see okay there's a bee lady over
here and we did confirm friendly fire
was on Khan I just want to shoot bee
lady I'm a shoe bee lady got a head shot
that is a head shot that's
awesome her heads like a beehive her
head is like on her hip and I shot her
head which was on her hip and that was a
head shot that was cool actually
I like those little touches currently PC
only but again we are just in an alpha
so who knows there was some interesting
stuff to some Chu player mechanics so in
the crematorium there was an elevator
with a crank you can actually okay
that's a heavy we do not want to mess
with this dude right here so am Bolin
gaming the dark vision is what you use
to find the clues and you need the clues
because that will lead you to the big
monster that you're supposed to kill on
the map that gives you the loot that you
want to then extract as you get more
clues I think Aaron said that you'll
like the players will start to kind of
converge to a that location so the map
is already shrunk to our area so we know
it's not in this area we know it's
actually where we are somewhere and then
that also increases the chances that
other players will start will start
encountering other players so we've
already found two players two or three
now which means the next one will
probably start encountering other
players okay so we gotta start being
careful I have a light on this character
and I'm gonna get rid of it next round
because there's no reason that you would
want to light it would just give you
away
now so that horse means another player's
where's that horse
usually they certain aim one of their
players are around watch that was just
robbed out there walking towards you
slowly where's this horse no he's right
here okay that's not that Kevin we were
saying that the Alpha is starting
tomorrow cool okay so oh for some reason
the email that we got from devs were
that our alpha was closing yeah but
maybe the close up of stops and open
alpha starts that would make sense
Tay is right let's mute it I don't know
if that's true or not that's I'm just
I'm listening to chat and I hope that's
not failing me right now now that makes
me probably look at I don't have the
internet at my hands I don't think I've
ever seen a dev have a one day alpha so
that would make sense that we we have
access to day ahead and then they're
gonna select invite people I believe
closed off exclusive the home will be e
on the following channels over the next
19 hours you don't wanna mess with that
guy he's a heavy that's a heavy I don't
see any thing about open alpha I just
got trolled
that would add up I'm not gonna swear by
it but oh they said they closed version
we're playing right now was only for 24
hours yeah it appears that way
wonder if they have any delicious death
eggs won't map up dated so are we on the
last part yet no we already know where
it is it's in the chapel which is due
east what do we yep we're gonna go do
east it's like a Western a walking dead
octane I am mildly concerned we haven't
run into any other teams yet
Danny Mac currently yes do you want to
go around hope I hear gunshots
very funny Jesse might have triggered
the dogs yep okay we can outrun them
though you did last time yeah it's
probably something the hot action here
at the chapel
assuming anyone else has found three
clues well maybe you guys can get to the
spider first for once then we get to all
see the spider is it big is it small it
is fast and skittery that's the worst
kind of sweater yeah well I don't know
we got nothing to lose then our entire
characters let's do this yeah it's alpha
let's go let's go see the spider
here we go okay
nope shots
there's definitely players here
potentially Southwest well they're not
shooting yeah now there's a gunfight
going down Southwest can jump over this
okay yeah you're going away from the
spider yeah but I'm going towards the
other players do the shooters in the
back wait are we monster hunting kind of
been there's planners over here I agree
I'm with Rob on this one all right just
go in get we could be fighting the
spider and have the other players
suddenly show up on us yes poppy Sepe
there are other players trying to get to
the same objective and killing the
monster which then drops some loot that
you want to extract so in some cases you
want to just kind of kill them to get
them out of the way or the old bait
would be that you let them kill it then
you kill them and then grab the loot and
run but there's multiple teams on the
map potentially
we're gonna have less teams of two or
there's something might be subsolar
players we have to move fast cuz
otherwise other players will just come
up on us while we're here and shoot us
in the back here okay there's definitely
gunfight going down over here there's
guys over here guys to our southeast we
want to rush in monster hunting van
helsing style a little bit I like the if
they're elitist watch watch South East I
think there might be a gunfight going
down over octane there is like leveling
up it unlocks weapons once you unlock
the weapons I believe someone chat had
mentioned that you don't lose those
you also level you're there in their
character but I mentioned you guys go in
and have a crazy fight with them and the
spider the spiders dead no actually just
kidding
they're shooting this fighter I think
the spider is dead they're banishing
right now get behind you all right good
job and dogs poop [ __ ] so yeah you
level up after each round assuming you
survive which then gives you like more
health and things like that are they
inside there or they're banishing it how
do you banish this level oh they gotta
know you're here right this is this
point
don't you I want a bandage yeah
Blanco says Kevin Lewis we Sheila flank
some heal their loot questions which
side is the flank the maps pretty
decent-sized yeah but it starts to
narrow down as you get - revs there
oh they're downstairs there's a
downstairs Oh we're gonna roll up on
them I hear them actually they probably
hear us I just said that out loud yeah
great job
any more than one way in yep there's
really stairway
well this is gonna be interesting in
like 40% there's no reason to get in
there right now daddy I think if there's
really only one exit you can pretty much
camp this stairwell and they're gonna
have to come out yeah but assuming
nobody rolls up on us
this barn is real vulnerable from like
every single angle Oh watch out this way
is that a zombie or a player okay this
is on me can't shoot them from the
outside yeah I like I like how you're
not even afraid that 101 will peak up
the stairs well they're banishing right
now I think they have to be on it
you think it's faster yep he said
grenade their grenading me where where
was that coming from Oh
can they just mess with you if you can
hear them too I guess the question is
good well they already know sound like
Rob no that's them they're just throwing
grenades oh it's on the move did they
just go outside how they're maybe
there's another it says it's on the move
Robert a on the move where oh yeah that
framerate yeah see there on the move man
there was another way out
uh-huh so that this grenades were
distractions
y'all got got dude they're so far how
did that even all right amateurs should
have went in after them question is are
they close to a extraction there were
some other teams over there so I don't
think it's so far I think it's so far
away
they're just bran we're shooting at
someone shooting at you nope right here
nice oh how did that one not here oh
nice shot come on Rob yeah took them
suck it all right
those aren't the guys though right I
don't leave those are the guys yeah I
know those guys we got a book in it we
got a book it no no crap don't go right
into that board that's gonna slow you
down
probably an underground tunnel yeah that
makes sense
it shouldn't be good it should
definitely not pigeonhole you into like
one exit that would be kind of dirty
yeah don't disagree where were they
going probably figure out where they're
headed
where's Rob Rob's way over there he's
going for the gold man spider or zombies
what is this game this hunt the show is
it hunt the show no it's just hunt
showdown you want to say hunt though
show Don hunt showdown by Crytek close
to alpha it's a mix of Wow ample games
if you want to call it that it's got
some kind of survival horror going on
it's got some PvP it's got some PvE
someone just said tarkoff and evolve
Aaron's gone with tarkoff and left for
dead
which Jesse Clare he hates and he's
gonna eat his hands now cuz I said
tarkoff and left for dead
I mean he's still there it's evolved
with okay we're catching up it's evolved
with way less mom did you check the map
to see where they're trying to extract
by Jason whenever and get a sight line
any good sight lines Rob he's part is
trying to get to them they are yeah
that's right we're coming for you we
don't care if we alarm the birds Oh God
bees Rob don't care Rob just going for
it
nope he's probably they came up nope
nevermind I was wrong
how's it guess sometimes you gotta make
it guess Wow
- they are running and so there might
actually be I saw in the purchase menu
there might be a shot a stamina shot
what don't quote me on that but there
might be a stamina shot that no it was
like speed up make you book it a bit
faster yeah but his teammate would kind
of have to well I think that's not
really
pretty much anvil 1 gaming all those
things all those emojis hands are now on
the menu no they're still going well did
you check this like I said did you check
the map to see where they can actually
run team you don't want to stop well the
thing is X no list I think that well one
the specs are now and two it's probably
not fully optimized yet so man whenever
you get in that tower there's a sight
line on where they're extracting the
graveyard go over the wall vaulting here
we go you've been here many times
there's a clue just triggered some birds
there's some zombo's there's still
running I totally I'm not anyone anymore
oh there goes that they got out all
right well you might as well go to that
extraction right yeah we back up the rug
Wow
they booked it that was well at least
you killed a group so there's that
somehow we've dropped a group every
round I this is the exact opposite of
what our morning was like I still want
to see that damn spider and I've yet to
see it I don't know if we'll be able to
I could give it one more girl where Rob
and I just we're we're still being
cautious I know I don't like it all
right
that's because you weren't there this
morning when bad stuff went down how
could they have extracted here with all
this crap here so they just run circles
is mine well get in the circle
I can level up Yaga then we're gonna try
to get that spider I will give it one
more go can shoot this horse so I don't
extract always say there's blood effects
we live to die another day we leave to
load another room pretty much to
matchmake all right let me hop into the
library of stuff you can buy real quick
and see if I've unlocked anything cool I
can well rank to five if you're close
you're gonna get the shotgun anything
shotguns really good against heavy
zombie enemies but other players you saw
we shot those guys in the water from a
good distance pistols are really slow
firing I've not had a lot of luck with
pistols as you see we got the first
Spider clue the second Spider clue the
third spider clue Oh so killing the
killing those zombies do give you XP
that's good that might be important
because again we've been doing pretty
good and we haven't died yet but we died
almost every round in the morning and
you just lose your hunters when you die
donors that's a lot killing the hunters
was almost a little like 40 percent nice
geez
hives kills grunts killed okay so it
shows you the cash rewards for hunting
nine grunts - hellhounds - hive so you
actually commissioned sales to forest
you can figure out all right let me hop
in the store really quick and see if
there's anything worth buying
one-handed loss that still walks for you
it's also but can we buy grenades which
okay here's the stamina shot I was
telling you about
although I think that's more for now I
think the stamina was for melee fights
what about some dynamite we should we
should always have dynamite and then
should be able to buy more health packs
I don't know if the sale thing is I
haven't found a lot of them in the
environment it's probably those so wait
I have to acquit first hunter so okay so
just so I can't equip a shotgun so the
only maybe okay so the risk is that you
would lose it when you die can you a
pistol I don't know it's not Lamy to you
right now but it looks like three so to
secondaries primary to secondary
can i unequip this worthless light
because it does nothing but give away my
position um we're tech we're totally
looking at chat horst but you've been
unless I'm mistaken pretty sure you're
the one that uh keeps talking crap about
the game what decided to keep watching I
guess oh sorry I've just hitting the
wrong button
yeah okay so equip oh but it took away
my machete which I don't want because we
don't want to go loud okay play another
round time for spider rush yeah we're
gonna do it hopefully we will attempt to
just move fast this time we will we
unfortunately he hasn't unlocked the
shotgun I think he had to be like rank
five or something
so the others are ready yep the only way
that I can
do that right now is to kill off two of
my characters because you actually get
in this alpha they just cycle through
the for starting characters over and
over again you lose one each time you
die but if you lose all of them then it
just gives all of them back to you the
shotgun is really good against heavy
zombies or other players at point-blank
range if you like what are the chances
of you getting that close that other
team they must have been distracting
they were throwing the grenades to buy
space and then they were must have been
an underground tunnel that we didn't
find yeah
in which case map knowledge is pretty
key yep I mean that's just how these
kind of game games go right is you need
to especially if there are like points
of interest where you're gonna have to
kill a monster you want to know if
there's multiple exits and where those
exits are and like I said there's also
there's a crematorium that I was a solo
player walking around in and there was
actually a crank with an elevator so I
don't I don't know what the advantage
would be of you lifting one teammate out
and staying down below maybe to buy them
time but there were some co-op mechanics
in the game like that where one person
has to open a door and the other person
goes through or like one person goes up
an elevator people are appreciating our
man jacking of that guy in the corner
with rifle butts I don't know if you saw
in the in the purchasing section but
there's actually a rifle that has blades
on the butt of it and I'm assuming I'm
assuming that thing does a lot more
damage when you rifle butt things it's
hilarious within kissing distance yes
yeah kissing is that one person in chat
who knows who they are it is not getting
a shoutout not from me for other reason
sure but not for that I think you guys
opportunity and this is the last match
we're gonna play we're gonna try to get
to that spider this time I try to get
that loot or at least go in guns blazing
even if someone's banishing it I guess
I'd like to think the person who told me
the three combination of keys you need
to hit two actually
iron sights that is big actually it took
us a while to figure out bandages so
even when you pull your bandage you
still have to aim and shoot the bandage
it's like a three button press for a lot
of things in this game what was
interesting though was that uh when you
were healing it gave it to you and
robbed so yeah that might have been my
class I don't I will mess around with
this a little bit more throughout the
day and maybe see if there's another we
don't know there might be another bill
tomorrow that's more open we'll see I
don't know that's what someone said but
I can find anything on the internet
about that
Romeo TV es asks can you steal another
Kings banish yes right yes they don't
extract it you can definitely do that we
just haven't been fast enough yeah Rock
1 m1 wants to know the specs of your PC
we have a 1080 in here high 7 I'm
assuming you don't know what it I didn't
help build that one so I'm not sure but
I'm my guess is that it for sure has a
1080 and it probably has an i7 in it
with probably at least 16 gigs of RAM if
not 32 but again it is a closed alpha in
which case I'm not sure if the game is
like optimized where you know different
builds of PCs and whatnot so they've got
these two-handed axes - you can pick up
at points and I don't really know why
yet maybe they're really good against
heavy zombie enemies or they're like one
shot against people yeah but so is that
double-barrel shotgun see you doc vlogs
we did Call of Duty World War 2 DLC this
morning we had some little hiccups in
the beginning what we eventually got to
it you know College ad DLC which also
had zombies yep we didn't play zombies
though unfortunately we just did some of
the new maps and the war mode so I've
got dynamite this time if we made to the
spider that might come in handy I have
this theory that throwing grenades is
only deadly to yourself most of the time
you just get shot while you're throwing
like 9 times out of 10 mm here yeah
sorry
fear jello uh currently it's only slated
for PCE but who knows it's just an alpha
right now close alpha alright so we're
starting by the slaughterhouse
yeah hopefully Kevin hopefully all right
you know sometimes I feel like with
alphas or betas if you're worried about
your PC build I generally if assuming
they have the settings I just lower them
quite a bit and just to play them play
it wow he is kind of teleporting as he
teleports in my favor I'll take it
catfish
I actually think we've started your toys
oh man Rob come on sorry he's just being
super natural you kill spiders with
dynamite that seems about right Jesse I
would do that too
can you carry too long weapons I have
not seen that yet I it looked like we
could carry to secondaries borromeo TV
didn't see max player account
I can't probably that up though to see
if they actually ever announced it yeah
already here again chance so now they
found the first clue and they're gonna
Marty hearing shooting to our West I
think this time Rob we just want to try
and book it to the spider if we can help
it oh you know what I think they're
fighting over that point already I want
to be careful that we don't get knocked
out early
so everybody sees the same points we had
that question earlier which causes
players to converge at the clue points
my being chased
sounded like a patter Bey zombie zombies
quite perturbed how many clues you guys
got just wondering one so far we're
heading towards another one but it is
Rob this is the guy we got Rob handler
another video producer here okay which
way do you want to try and ambush him
from we're currently playing on Steam
he's in the white house
and here you guys talking
oh we going down just wavin everybody
another hunter is bouts that possibly
die here
a shotgun okay will that kill Rob
[Applause]
waiting for that guy to come get you
gotta reload buddy guessing you have to
stop running okay well this is awkward
hey f to pay respects press f to pay
respects to Rob yeah okay I was chasing
me question is I said screw it and left
you so that's actually what happened
this morning Rob and I got a little
impatient went after somebody in a house
who had a shotgun
the question is where did he go is he in
the woods behind me he definitely was
shooting at me from behind you can still
pick Rob up right
yeah but he's probably can't be his body
which actually might work in my favor
for that dynamite rob is almost gone
never wanna go the rest of stream with
that Rob so let's do this
you can get in there in time I'm gonna
go back in the same door which is dude
they had to have heard us no [ __ ] Rob
proximity chat don't say I didn't tell
you so you know Anya yes right there
Oh should have tossed it I was like you
know he has a shotgun all right well
that's what we get Rob is almost dead
hey it doesn't matter you should do that
dynamite he threw that dynamite you you
told you said it yourself anyways that
was the hunt showdown Crytek's new game
no really state yet that was closed
alpha so fun game kind of combination of
multiple games it's you can either play
solo or be paired with another hunter as
we were today Aaron Rob we're playing
together here basically looking for
clues to kind of thin out the map to
then try to kill a monster that's at the
end of the map that gives you some loot
that you want to extract but there's
monsters and zombies and also other
hunters trying to kill you to get that
loot and now let me show you real quick
since this hasn't happened yet you
actually lose your hunter which is why
you don't really necessarily want to
rush things or die
so now he has to technically so that
owner is Joe hunter yeah
so your level seven is gone dead now you
got to either buy Joseph Howard or
Robert Fitzgerald so he has the antidote
shot this is what we're talking about
earlier gotcha carry an additional tool
right and then this guy has a shotgun
there's a guy with a suppressed pistol
time you had like five bars of health so
that kind of sucks that to start over
yeah do you that guy drop five bars of
health in one shotgun blast yeah well
you were real close I did get a
hitmarker
that's true but you had a normal rifle
which probably takes like two shots to
kill ya thrown that dynamite I said it
out loud yeah anyways yeah so that's a
little show for you guys and thank eyes
all for tuning in we stream it every day
at 11 a.m. thanks Aaron for playing
thank you and see you guys
potentially tomorrow we've been kind of
filling in the lobby days as like as I
can if not definitely Thursday and
Friday so until next time see you guys
later
thank you so much